[Music]
hi everybody uh
i am just coming off of a box of kleenex
that i used in the recording of this
episode with sarah seeger
on the occasion of her magnificent
memoir known as the smallest lights in
the universe
uh this is a very emotional episode for
me dealing with some painful
issues that she and i share and so i
don't share with her
that she's managed to get through and
and just really left me uh emotionally
drained but in a good way
uh she's a lovely human being she's an
incredible astronomer
a phenomenal mentor and scientist i know
you're going to love this episode uh you
may want to keep a box of kleenex in all
seriousness nearby
uh especially if you have read this book
uh because it is a work of art it's a
gift to
uh to those of us who suffer who deal
with loss
at the deepest levels and there's no one
i'd rather go into the impossible with
than professor sarah seeger of mit
she did you know she did
humor me and go into the impossible with
my final three questions you won't want
to miss those
you will miss them if you don't
subscribe to this channel
uh via uh the uh via youtube and via
itunes or wherever else you follow or
get podcasts
but uh but to get her answers in a
special thrilling three final questions
that i ask all my guests who
agree to go into the impossible the only
way to get those is to subscribe at
brianketing.com to my mailing list
and then you will get them so i hope
you'll do that and
uh and you won't regret it because this
is one of the deepest
uh most moving interviews i've ever done
and it just
further solidifies my mission in
bringing these magnificent minds
to you my beloved listeners viewers
out there in the in the world who have
soul
and spirit and indomitable ability
to journey along with real human beings
that's what i want to do i want to
humanize scientists
including sometimes myself because i can
be robotic with the best of them
but i want to humanize people and uh and
and really it was such a delight and
honor and a thrill to talk to sarah
today i know you will enjoy it and i
know you'll help me
in this mission by just coming along
that's all you need to do
uh on a ride into the impossible today
journeying to the smallest lights in the
universe
with professor sarah seeger of mit
and joy any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
and i have a copy of today's guest's
spectacular book is called the smallest
lights in the universe
it's professor sarah seeger i've been a
fanboy
uh for many years actually of sarah's
work
even long before she wrote this really
monumental book which i can't really
talk too much about
unfortunately sarah because i'll get
very emotional i'm being
completely honest with you i've never
read a book like this before
i'm sure you've heard praise and comey
from from all others around the world
including all the wonderful reviews you
got on the back of the book temple
grandin
publishers weekly kirkus reviews i want
to go deep but i'm afraid i'm afraid sir
i don't want to get too emotional
because
it really resonated a lot with me but i
want to first congratulate you and thank
you
for this gift that you've given to the
world this book called the smallest
lights in the universe
in addition to all the gifts you've
given in terms of other worlds that
you've helped to discover we'll talk
about that
first i want to ask you thank you and
ask you how are you doing today
doing well thanks it's a spring here
springtime here and it's
it's warming up and it's it's it's good
yeah
life is good in the springtime uh so
you know i followed your career we're
about you know kind of contemporaries
and age and i've always found with you
uh that i was never i was never jealous
of your success i just saw it and i was
just
astounded i felt as they said of when
stephen hawking
met jakob zeldovich who is a mentor of
the
one of my close mentors alex palmer uh
stephen hawking said i didn't think you
really existed i thought you were a
collective
like borbaki and i thought that about
you until
you know very recently when i discovered
you are an individual
so the first thing i want to ask as i do
with all my guests it kind of gets us
into the flow of the conversation
is this book has a title and uh and
a very small subtitle the subtitle is a
memoir i want to ask you as i ask people
which is the advice that you're never
supposed to judge a book by its cover
i always judge books by its cover and i
assume a lot of effort went into
choosing not only the cover
but the title and i want to ask you
where did you come up with it what's the
origin story
of the title and like on the cover
design of this book
well the title actually has two
different
meanings and you're supposed to get it
yourself from reading the book but i
will i'll give the spoiler
the smallest lights of the universe the
smallest lights in the universe
it refers to the other earths we're
trying to find out
are we alone are there planets like our
own earth out there
now our earth is very faint it's you
know as seen from afar our own earth
it shines in reflected light from the
star from our sun
and our earth believe it or not it's 10
billion times fainter than our sun
so when we're looking for these other
earths they are the smallest lights in
the universe
and of course it sort of has a double
entendre if i'm not mistaken yeah
it's the book that describes both my
professional journey through space
and also my personal journey think of it
like the journey of outer space and the
journey of inner space
and in the journey of inner space it has
a more
lonely meaning meaning even and if you
think those earths just out there
floating through the vastness of space
it seems a bit lonely but
this other sense it's the it's about
grief and depression and
when you're like fall off a cliff into
the deep abyss
what kind of pulls you out of that are
are the little tiny glimmers of hope
you have to hold on to those and those i
also call the smallest lights in the
universe
and it's uh it's a story of multiple i'm
already getting emotional this is no
good
it's never happened you know when i talk
to sir roger penrose i don't i don't
choke up like this
but it's like he didn't write a yeah he
didn't write i guess he didn't write
that personal
person no he doesn't and and most of the
other including your
your colleague down the hall as i uh
remember frank wilcheck who's been on
the show four times like you i should
point out your
it's your fourth appearance uh at least
your third appearance i think it might
be your third appearance but this is the
first one on one
uh where we haven't been talking uh with
a
group a true collective of astronomers
as we have in the past and i'll put
links somewhere here
there for people to find your previous
appearances on the end to the impossible
podcast but it's a love story
it's a series of love stories um it's a
story of self-love
and kind of discovery as well it's very
unusual
and you know you point out that you know
a lot of the things that you go through
in this book
there's no manual um my my own father
passed away when i was about the same
age your father was
uh when he passed away of a similar kind
of malady and
you know i remember the experience i had
after it of
i i felt scared for my own life that
that not that i was going to die the
exact same thing which you know
obviously there's some probability if
your parents have cancer we should take
this opportunity for people to get
screened
and so forth as a service but but
actually that i was kind of lost
and without an anchor or mooring and
floating through space
um i wonder i wasn't you know um i
wasn't
married at that time i didn't have any
children um when you were going through
these episodes um what was you know kind
of
your your solace or at least the first
time because i i don't think there's
anything that can prepare of it it's not
that much of a spoiler to say also your
husband michael pass
passed away your your first husband and
and i should say first of all i want to
thank your
your husband charles darrow who put us
in touch many months ago
when news of uh phosphine discovery on
venus took place we'll talk about that
later
uh so shout out to charles who's a
fellow amateur astronomer but
also you know it's semi-professional in
some ways too but
you went through this these series of
tragedies that no one should really
experience for for many you know until
they're much older but there's no
handbook
there's no instruction manual as
complicated as the instruction manual
that you wrote
for nasa for a star shade that's
complicated at least it exists
when you have a child when you lose a
parent there's no instruction manual
there's no instruction manual on how to
write a book like this how how did you
do it
well there's a lot of questions in there
but you were first going to ask me if i
had an anchor
and i suppose i did actually and one of
my anchors was my children
because as you know anyone who's had
children if they're really little like
two years old you know you can't ignore
them
and just go off on your own little
universe of grief
and the other was my work i just love my
work and being able to focus on it
everything goes away and my work was my
solace actually
does it happen to you brian like you
start programming or whatever your
thing is and you just get so absorbed in
it
and the other stuff just goes away for a
while it does
it does and certainly you know um as i
as i think
mit alum richard feynman once said you
know
at least as a professor uh you have your
teaching
because if you fall you know into dis
disarray with your research you can
always say i'm doing something
productive and in fact that's one of the
highest callings there is
one thing i learned from this professor
uh alex palmerev
my mentor who was communicated to him by
his mentor yaakov zeldovich
was that the word scientist in russian
means someone who was taught
prime means a man who was taught but be
that as it may
it means someone who was taught and it
made me think
we have an obligation because we were
taught and and you talk about the roles
of your father
and and of kind of the stars and your
work as a type of teacher
as a mentor and guiding you but you
strike me as someone who's always been
incredibly independent and and
um not not necessarily you know to prove
other people wrong i think sometimes
people use this like
their rejections and failures like
rocket fuel to propel them to do better
and i'll show
you your high school girlfriend or
boyfriend or rejected
no i don't i don't get that sense at all
i think i think it is true
that our work can can can do that for me
also i have to say it is my
my burgeoning faith or curiosity about
existential questions and i do want to
talk to you about that
um obviously you know i'm jewish my
religion uh precludes me from prostitute
i never proselytize in case you're just
joining this channel
uh you know it seems much more emotional
than it than it normally is and
that's okay we have a diversity of
different uh topics on on this show
uh but yeah it's true you can lose
yourself in your work
um but but not having children not being
my older brother was married and had
children
and i remember wondering it was easier
for him was it harder when we lost our
father
to have children or not and you know i
wonder i only had my teaching
in other words and it's not the same
yeah i don't think there's i don't think
any one case is easier than another
honestly so i want to talk about the
other thing that i communicated with mit
alum there's gonna be a lot i mean mit
has had
next to maybe ucsd has had the most uh
representation on the into the
impossible podcast i've had michael
saylor
i've had andrew viterbi i've had jim
simons
all these mit alums one of my favorite
is of course uh jenna levin
mit alum and i also had katie freeze who
is at mit who was a professor at mit
as well so um i want to ask you
uh when i talked to jana her first book
was sort of a memoir too
called how the universe got its spots a
delightful book
a book of science as your book is a
memoir but i said to her you know
was it risky to write a memoir first of
all you're so young
she was so young when she wrote she
didn't even have a faculty job at least
you know
you were already tenured you know full
professor when you wrote this book
you came into mit as one of the rare
people that they actually tenure ahead
of time
and that's well deserved and of course
you've had tremendous accomplishments
we'll put those in the bio somewhere i
don't think that's the reason i'm
talking to you today
this this magical book is really just
it's impossible to
to not be over overwhelmed by it in a
good way
what gave you the confidence as uh to
write a memoir as
a an astronomer you know be or a
scientist a woman in science
you know at one of the most prestigious
places on earth and earth's history
to be a scientist is this not a risky
maneuver for someone like yourself
well i never actually thought about that
question and to be honest
what was going through my mind was when
i was widowed
it was a crazy journey honestly it was
still bizarre and unreal and it was
incredibly
everything was magnified like imagine
being happy or sad or frustrated all of
those are like a million times more
and i remember when i met my widow
friends
which we might get to but i just asked
them like wow are you ready to book on
this someone
one of us we we have to tell the world
about this it's so crazy
and that was my main motivation was to
just share that journey
and it wasn't enough for a book and the
book sort of morphed into this like
whole life story thing
but another reason i wrote it and i
don't know if this speaks to every
single person who reads it
is i was trying to give people a wake-up
call you know
like life can change in the blink of an
eye
and we have to try to make the most you
know of what we have or what we can do
and try to make that change that allows
us to have purpose
and we'll we'll certainly talk more
about that in you know specific
uh details over further reader you know
i hate when i would go on podcasts and
say you know
can you tell us the exact contents of
your book chapter by chapter summary
you know so my audience can save 19 in
the audiobook i have the audio book i
have the
uh the printed copy and um
and it is a sort of how-to guide
um how to cope with grief of course
everyone is different as you say there
is no manual just like in a in a
you know near drunken only thing i can
analogize it to is a drunken stupor when
your first child is born
there's nothing that can prepare you uh
for when your first child is born as you
know especially doing most of the work
you know men are limited to a few
minutes at best uh but
uh but nevertheless that first night my
son is home
and like he's crying i'm like i'm
getting twice as much sleep as my wife i
don't know how she survived
but um but then i'm like get the
instruction manual
like you know where's the instruction
like there is no freaking instruction
manual
uh and there is because every kid is
different um and the and i was talking
to a very good friend
a rabbinical figure in my life last
night and
and he was saying like it's just amazing
because the fact that we survive
especially like you and i are like
really curious we love doing stuff and
you had all these adventures you talk
about in the book
like we it's a miracle that we survived
and like i have all my fingers like
i i'm grateful to my mom and my you know
my father of blessed memory
uh you know for at least allowing me to
come into adulthood with all my
extremities uh but kids never really
appreciate that and and i wonder if it
if you resonate with this the you know
aristotle said many things
most of which in physics were wrong you
know heavy bodies fall faster than
lighter ones
there are four elements instead of 114
but one thing he said is that you know
um parents love their children more than
children love their parents
and the reason he says was the sacrifice
that parents do and i actually think the
mother children love their mothers more
than their father you know
spoiler alert you know for me maybe or
other fathers out there because the
mother sacrifices even more
uh how much of your career were you
willing to sacrifice
um to ease the pain of course you
couldn't completely you could never
erase the pain of the memory
how much explore that a little bit that
you seem to me
you seem that you sacrifice your
tremendousness or you were willing to
and and things work out obviously you
know well enough
in some ways but but how did you come to
that conclusion that you were going to
sacrifice whatever it took for your kids
the thing is i don't know that i really
thought it through like if you look back
it might look that way but i wasn't like
okay let me make my pie chart of how
much time i have for this or that and
a weighted function about where i should
be spending my time and how i just sort
of
just like you described when the first
born is born you don't really
have a plan you just kind of go with it
and when um you have these opportunities
i like it because now
you know you explored a lot more
obviously as a woman in science which
which i think would be good to talk
about
you were dealing with sometimes a lot of
men in science and sometimes even women
or men that didn't have children
and i find this quite frequently i get a
lot of complaints i hear a lot of
complaints
why are parents getting so much free
time during covet or relief etc etc
um and you talk about in in great detail
how you had to arrange your
like to get a prize the sackler award
was one of the most prestigious prizes
in astronomy
you had a like like you went to israel
for like two days right i mean like
who does that well there's a lot of
different factors
and certainly i'm just trying to
remember now because i'm in this
wonderful phase
where my children are almost grown up
you know my oldest will be 18 soon and
they can cook and they're very
responsible
they can shop and cook they've had a job
they can manage money the older one has
been driving for over a year
so like we're kind of almost there but
when they were little it's a lot
because yeah it's really tough the one
you're talking about was i was a single
mom
and as you know like in academia we tend
to move around so we don't have family
nearby
and many of us are somewhat estranged
from our family let's say
also as people have kids older and older
the grandparents are old
too old to you know effectively take
care of the kids
so i don't have anybody and then i got
this wonderful award
and you have the one thing about this
sackler prize is
you actually have to physically go to
israel to participate in the talks and
and
to receive the award and i was just like
wow i'm going to be half a world away
from my kids
and at that time i didn't have anyone
else i was widowed i didn't have anyone
i could trust like to take care of them
overnight what if something went wrong
this is what's going through my head but
if they break their leg or they
don't get hit by a car like that's just
parenting anxiousness how can i be that
far away because you can't just
get on the bus and come home like even
if you plan by the next flight it's
might be a day later and then it takes a
day to get back as you know you've got
to change planes in new york and the
lines are really long or they were
oh that's going through my head like i
just don't know and then i just thought
of the one person who i
i could trust which was the children's
aunt aunt rachel and i
i just explained it to her it's like i
really can you please come here
for a few days and she did
and so that yeah really highlighted to
me that you know
the world you might not have thought
about that right right a lot of people
just wouldn't have
have uh the funny thing is the other
thing women would stress about like what
could what should i wear oh my god
but okay that's not equal to like a
continental way
no that's right you talk there's other
things too like i just remember one time
um
i waited till i had a permanent job
and i had a cash flow so i could hire a
nanny like it all worked out i tried to
have kids young but i got a job
so that i could just
have my life a bit easier but anyway the
nanny showed up at a certain time
and then there was a meeting in town for
one of my collaborations but that
meeting started slightly before
you know i'd have time to get ready and
drive and park at this meeting
and i just remember how hard it was like
to wake up the two little little
kids and you know it's like
breastfeeding one kid like getting them
dressed whatever they need
getting them somehow keeping the morning
going getting myself like
looking half decent you know even
getting a shower is like nearly
impossible
and then getting to the meeting i
remember all i had to do and i got to
that meeting on time which was probably
like 8 a.m or 8 30. i got into my seat
and i was like
no one has any idea what i did up until
this quarter like how
house an uphill battle i had to to just
get to that meeting on time like awake
caffeinated dress yeah yeah it's like
that and so that happened a lot and now
of course i don't have that now and i've
forgotten until
these questions what how hard it was but
there's definitely a lot a lot of that
yeah let's conquer this you know before
covet we were always traveling all the
time and
you know just how to handle the
conferences when
even when i um was married to my first
husband it's a real burden to
to leave the kids behind with him yeah
yeah my for my part i i think about
things in terms of
you know shabbat like the friday night
dinner
you get a thousand of them with each kid
you know 20 18 years times 52 weeks a
year
and i asked myself and i've given up a
lot you know in terms of you know
not the level of prestige that that you
would have been if you turned down the
sackler award but
but nevertheless you know meetings and
just professional kind of relations and
and playing a different role and i've
tried to rekindle some of that through
these podcasts where i get to
you know have all the fun of meeting
brilliant colleagues
uh without gaining you know the 10
pounds that i typically do
you know from all the muffins and
sedentary activity
so this this this podcast is my attempt
at uh
at the dieting and uh but also mental uh
feeding my mind
and when i you know but i kept couldn't
help but think when i read
this book um something i thought about a
little bit
which is um which is that this is the
only time i'm ever going to be able to
write these words
in that you know it's not like a journal
you know where we i've made
you know errata you know i've i've had
to submit corrections
and and you might know of a certain
event that led to this thing behind me
there you know or
it was very i've read the book so yes
but but you can you can retract right
you can recant you can
but a memoir you can't retract although
charles barkley the famous nba
basketball player said he was misquoted
in his autobiography and that that takes
a lot but
but i want to ask you you know putting
this in amber you know freezing this
this time uh i a i couldn't help but be
impressed because
i know like i say as a man i can only
know a fraction of what a woman
in science must go through but i have
great respect i have you know sympathy
if i can't empathize or
empathy if i can't sit with i don't know
which one is which but but the point
being
um that and i kept thinking like i don't
care about these prizes i
actually have come to a a sense of being
settled with
the nobel prize with any prize but i
want to live to impress myself
and i and i kept reading your book and i
said like you must be impressed with
yourself not like i don't mean it at all
sarah arrogantly
but you've done so much um was that kind
of liberating to put it on paper and
like did it clarify as sauron
kierkegaard said
you know life must be lived forward but
can only be understood looking backwards
and i would see that as a
metaphor for the telescope like did
these things make sense
in retrospect or or were they worth it
obviously
not the death of somebody but like the
challenges the struggles that you went
through
you're very candid about your you know
uh the the
the the different you know kind of
challenges you had learning issues
and what have you that you overcame um
and and uh and so forth was this
kind of liberating to put it in amber
well you know yes and no i think from
the science side i don't really dwell
too much on the past i'm always like
fixated on the next thing the next
journey
and let's get make sure we talk about
venus at some point
yeah of course i really more looking
forward than looking back but sometimes
when i look back
it's only to
remind myself that i can like the venus
thing is somewhat complex because we
have a
mission we want to send more than one
mission to venus
and so if i need to look back it's only
say look i did that stuff before i can
definitely do this
other more ambitious stuff now but the
book was
liberating just from the personal
viewpoint to get all that out it was
incredibly cathartic it's almost like
do you ever have i don't know if men do
this but for women girl talk you always
talk to your friends
and you dump stuff and then all of a
sudden you feel better
but your friend just feels a lot worse
and so it's sort of like that with a
book i just feel so good
yeah but i know every people time people
read it like you
especially it strikes a chord or strikes
a nerve with some people and then they
feel bad
so i feel a bit bad about that but i
just feel liberated for
just getting it all together and making
sense of all all the personal stuff i
think
which is really tough well carl sagan
had his widow andrew ian on my podcast
as well as his daughter
sasha sagan who's an amazing author and
they're they're the first
mother-daughter
team soon i'm going to have jim gates
another mit
alum who's been on the show three times
but i'm going to have him and his
daughter
delilah who's getting a phd at your at
your alma mater at harvard uh with andy
strominger
uh but but thinking back you know in in
kind of
this this way that you handled you know
these setbacks and challenges
i think i look at you and i see
potentially correct me if i'm wrong
you were kind of hooked as a kid uh
astronomy and and really that the sky in
some sense became
a form of therapy and you just talked
about like this this conversation with
your
with your girlfriends and yeah i do it
too it's called my therapist no i don't
have a therapist i'm actually going to
be
but i am going to start advertising a
therapy company
at some point as has reached out to me
to do advertising and first i was like
you know
i don't need that you know whatever and
they're like you get a free session with
our psychologist
and i'm like is that enough you know do
i get any drugs in this
no i'm just kidding i'm not going to get
any drugs but but i started thinking
like i've
i used to have a personal trainer you
know years ago or i do martial arts i
have a coach
uh a flight instructor when i do my
little putting around the sky
uh and so what's wrong with having a
therapist you know what's wrong with
having and if people don't have it in
their
in their family or their spouse or their
partner they don't have partners
uh there's no stigma in my mind to doing
it because it's really trying to perfect
yourself right and and coach yourself
and make yourself better
by the way just one second because yeah
my i just realized my computer's not
plugged in so i'm just going to just
before i have
sorry sorry let me just pause it for a
second um
okay so we're back yeah go ahead yeah so
i actually did go to therapy for about
two years
before i had my own children i thought
my childhood was
it was so destructively traumatic i had
to sort through all that because i
wanted to be healed
before i had my own children so i'm not
sure where this thread was going but i
really support
it if you find the right person yeah no
i agree
and and you know one of my rabbis has
said to me something like
you know and rabbis are you know
ministers priests whatever they can
serve a similar role but they've said
things like
you know our job as parents is to pass
along only half of our neuroses to our
kids you know
if we all do that after you know 10
generations there'll be almost no
trace of our of our original starting
point
but i want to talk about uh as in
physics we often talk about differential
equations and
and of course these need to be solved
applying both boundary conditions and
initial conditions i want to talk about
your initial conditions what got you
into astronomy
and you talk candidly about high school
and it's just so funny because i'm like
visualizing
you like you're probably very you know
appealing to the opposite sex or
i don't know the same who knows but but
you were probably attractive and you
didn't realize that you were talking
about that and like you never really
realized it
and then but it's like your telescope
became
this this magical device and and how
ironic is it that your
your avocation became your vocation who
can you talk about that my
my kick lately is that it's a crime
it's a moral crime if parents don't buy
their kid at least this ten dollar
keating brand telescope because
even from mit even from cambridge
massachusetts even from san diego
you can see all the craters on the moon
you can see all the planets
that galileo that newton that all these
greatest the bands of jupiter and the
moons of jupiter and the moons change
and saturn's rings of saturn's oriented
favorably
it's amazing what you can see so i see
that as a gateway drug that
if not applied if not injected into
their minds
could prevent another sarah seeger so
can you say something to parents out
there
i get this all the time what's the best
way to get my kids into a straw boys and
girls of course
you know we're seeing a large
development since you were young i'm
speaking from the office of
jeff burbidge the late great jeff
burbidge whose wife margaret was one of
the founders
of uh of you know base a tremendous
amount
of astronomical entities including the
department sub department that i'm in
here
which you will be speaking at next week
by the way i can't wait for that
that zoom event i cannot wait by the
time this is out it'll probably be over
uh but i'm looking forward in in
retrospect to it
uh i want to talk about that how do you
tell a parent what would you advise a
parent
to to experiment or to encourage a
nascent incipient love of science or
maybe astronomy
specifically well in general i think
it's great to expose your kids to all
kinds of things
not just science but speaking of science
and astronomy specifically
and brian maybe you know of uh well
people are listening to this from all
over but i really recommend once we're
back to normal let's call it finding a
local astronomy club that holds
a public star party night and so then
you don't have to buy anything you don't
have to do anything complicated you can
go to the star party
look through the telescopes the
astronomers the amateur astronomers will
know
you know they'll be pointing to
interesting things i think that's a
really great way to get started
and whatever the equivalent of that is
for other sciences as well it's so
important to expose your kids to things
otherwise all they find is what's on tv
yeah or youtube well i don't want them
to turn off the into the impossible
channel please
do not do that ladies and gentlemen i
need the the ad revenue no i'm just
kidding i don't make that much but um
but speaking about high school and kind
of not fitting in that's where i
discovered astronomy i
i fell in love with the heavens i found
it um sheltering i found i felt it
welcoming to kind of engage with these
minds as carl sagan uh
used to say you know a book is proof
that humans can work magic because you
can talk to somebody or listen to
somebody who's dead for hundreds of
years
uh and they're speaking inside your head
and they're sort of visualizing their
voice or oral light whatever it is
called
um and for you know for this book and
kind of thinking back in my high school
experience i didn't fit in and i wonder
is that a bad thing you know in other
words
yeah of course bullying is is horrible
and horrendous and should not be
countenanced but
but you know i was i was sort of out of
place i i wasn't like a jock i wasn't
like
i was into astronomy that was kind of
weird in the 80s right
um to be like halley's comet oh you seem
so
uh friendly and outgoing and popular now
so it's hard to reconcile that in the
interview in high school well i've had
i've had a lot
of makeovers and no no i haven't i
actually haven't
i i feel like it in some sense i once
heard from a friend who went to school
in the berkshires not far from where you
live and hike and do stuff and he said
their motto was like
it's good for a college to be at the
bottom of a hill like when you get to a
place like mit
you might be tempted to think i really
made it like whereas you were kind of
you told me before we started recording
you actually got rejected you know
before every other step
before you became a tenured per you
people know how rare that that's like
getting into the major leagues you know
on your whatever the first draft pick
that sarah did and it's well deserved
but i think not fitting in
in high school kind of gave me that
armor a little bit of the toughness that
i would need
to survive some of the slings and error
that i think i mean you've experienced a
lot of that in your career do you think
that that high school experience was
formative in any sense in terms of your
mental toughness
absolutely and it's not just about
mental toughness
it's about being able to not fit in in
science as well
so if i have an idea or something i want
to pursue
and the rest of the world scientific
world or astronomy world is telling me
that's ridiculous that's dumb don't do
that that's impossible
then i could ignore that because i was
comfortable not being
someone who fit in and did mainstream so
it was incredibly beneficial i'd say
do you feel that there is sort of um
this
lovely delightful delicious aspect of
escapism
in the work that you do somewhat of the
work that i do where you know i'm
looking for origins of maybe
multiple universes and you're looking
for life and habitable worlds
each you say in the book stars are magic
you say things like
these other worlds just the thought of
them is magical is delightful
as they say delicious mentally delicious
and that there's probably life
and you were called in front of congress
and you were asked you know to do the
math for them because you know our
congressional
you know great great fathers mothers
they can't do the math
themselves and they wear that with like
a badge of pride it's like no one would
say
i can't read english you know like i'm
so cool like
i'm not good at those words and sticks i
think he was kind of teasing in a way
though i think you know if we just sort
of wrote out all the zeros on the
blackboard he he'd get it
yeah so when you look at uh what's
become known as seeger's law
and you think about these uh the fermi
paradox in that context
do you feel ever that there is sort of
an escapism i actually talked to
somebody you'll you'll probably ridicule
me i hope you won't but i talked to
somebody who's in a proponent of what's
called intelligent design
he's he's actually a well-known he wrote
of you know two number one best-selling
new york times books
his name is stephen meyer he's a phd in
philosophy from cambridge
in england not the cambridge urine the
og cambridge england
and uh and and he was saying you know
that like most of the
cop the the kind of criticism that he
gets is like
well life originated on some other
planet and then came here in what's
called panspermia i guess it sounds
dirty but it's not
but uh but anyway that that explains the
origin of life on earth but
i was saying that seems like it pushes
it farther and farther back
and i'm wondering is it escapist you
know when we fantasize about other
planets
uh harboring life those posters that you
have outside your office that you talk
about
um is there an escapist element or or
you know is it because we're not
satisfied with planet earth or is it
something else
it's a i think it is definitely some
kind of escapism
you know we love science fiction movies
people love reading science fiction it's
i think along those lines in many ways
dreaming about the possibilities out
there
what are your thoughts on that i think
that um
i find it uh a fun game you know kind of
to speculate on intellectually speaking
i think that people don't really
appreciate how
hard it is you know if you really go
through seeger's law you know which is
kind of a
modern day version of the drake equation
uh and i've had on the drake you know
professor
uh jill tarter on my show many times as
well
and you know it's kind of an
encapsulation of our ignorance
and what i always point out is what you
would probably do the same
at mit if one of your students
undergraduates hands in a paper
and it has all these numbers on it but
no uncertainties and i say the
uncertainties are the hard part about
science it's actually not so hard to
calculate the
the expectation value but the the sigma
the the statistical the systematic
errors
and they could be as large as 100
percent and i and i start thinking
well you know what's wrong with earth
you know not that like i often feel like
this and i heard this actually in the
context of venus life which we're gonna
get to
and it was like it wouldn't be amazing
you know if we found
evidence for life it would mean that
we're not alone in in some cosmic sense
you know
and that would mean that there's high
probability okay that's true but like
right now
you and i are 99.7 similar to
chimpanzees and bonobos
and yet we never go around saying oh
like is it amazing like we're not alone
on planet earth like we already take it
for granted i feel like the day after
you are successful
and i pray to god that you will be
successful in all that you do
but but i but i feel like the next day
will go on as life with
life as usual and i actually have a
proof for that but but let's keep going
um
uh what do you think i mean this this
notion that we
we there has to be other life i i think
like why don't we look on earth and say
how magical and wonderful it is to be on
earth
and and and kind of say we should be
satisfied
not that we shouldn't look but but isn't
that enough it's not anything how you
say that because
it's an and not an ore it doesn't have
to be oh life is amazing on earth
or it's so great to try to find life
elsewhere we can do all those things
and i often find you know feynman again
mit alum
uh i should look up what year he
graduated but but he you know he said
like
why is it okay to wax poetically about
jupiter
if he's a greek god but it's not okay if
he's just a ball of methane
and and i started thinking well you know
i don't know how much
like people say oh we're just like
cosmic pollution and we're cosmic you
know
uh star stuff uh as as as many people
have said
um i don't know that that makes me feel
bigger in a sense like i feel like
we are the only known form of life we're
certainly the only
technological life that doesn't preclude
it yeah as you say and
statements are powerful um but i kind of
feel like we don't appreciate how good
we
are or how unique and magical we are on
earth and i'm not
you know i'm all for looking and
hopefully finding even uh but
uh and maybe we'd be able to do that
with technology that my colleagues and i
are building on the simon's observatory
but
i don't think do you think people would
react differently let's say tomorrow
unequivocal evidence proof positive
whatever that means in signs
uh there is is some life form on venus
uh producing phosphate
do you think that humanity would react
differently three weeks later
would it make us like feel less lonely
perhaps or that we're you know less
significant or more significant
i can't tell what it would do but i'm
always told that it's a really good
thing
you know that we do right i honestly
think it depends on each individual
there's plenty of people out there
they're not the ones listening to your
podcast
who would just be meaningless you know
it doesn't change your life on a
day-to-day basis
that's true yeah there's other there's
others for who
it would be huge because having life on
another planet
it's somehow it conflicts with the
creation story
and there's another group who you know
in their free time might wonder wow
that's great and then three weeks later
they may go back to just
okay their everyday life but you know
there's uh but back to your point about
earth let's switch topics for a second
yeah there are so many amazing things on
earth i agree like
think about the life i was just i don't
know what twitter feed or what social
media i get but
someone was going on about life at the
bottom of the ocean you know these
hydrothermal vents it's amazing
when people first discovered the complex
life deep down at the bottom of our
ocean
made possible by the energy coming off
of these vents they just couldn't
believe it that was like discovering
life on another world in that sense
and i feel like there's so many chances
for that here on earth whether you're
learning it for the first time
like recently on twitter too someone and
went on and on
and it got quite a following about this
type of bacteria that does
photosynthesis
off of heat like not uv light at the
bottom of the ocean it uses heat energy
we've already known about this for a
long time it just sort of got recycled
and so you see that
re-excitement the first time you learn
about something or just how intelligent
octopuses are there's so many wonderful
things on our planet i agree
yeah so thinking about going out
further into the universe we'll come to
venus in a little bit
uh a large portion of the book is kind
of the the
quotidian struggle to get uh
to to take care of business as a
professor as an astronomer
and most people think that we sit around
and we you know we just gaze up at the
heavens and we
we're waxing rhapsodically about it and
so forth but actually it's a lot about
like
why did that graduate student you know
finish you know her
her prelim in time so that she could
deploy to chile to take data for this
you know it's
or it's like the concrete's not there or
i've got this 198-page
you know loi yeah there's a large part
of your job and my job
that is like any other manager's job
really you have to have the strategy the
staffing the budget plan
the project management and you've got to
make sure everything happens
when it's supposed to so the whole
project can move forward it's so true
and they don't i don't know do they at
mit is there any training on like how to
be a professor
how to run a lab how to be a manager in
fact
the problem is that when i see all of my
peers in industry
so much training oh my gosh one of my
friends works at a financial company
and she got trained on how to give a
better talk a two-day
very intensive very expensive workshop
and it's like huh
like like brian have you ever been asked
by your work to take
a class on how to give a better talk no
i was thinking if she's saying that i
should take that and i actually later
signed up for that class
and they're constantly one of my other
colleagues got a class on
how to deliver bad news and that's about
firing people so the thing is that we
really do need to be more aware of that
and self-train or
watch free videos or use money ask your
department head if you have
discretionary money use that and take it
on yourself to train
it's very unusual to be in an industry
where there's no no training but
huge responsibility and expectations
yeah i would say we're kind of like uh
small business people except we don't
really make a profit we just get
citations
but we have this that's nice you're like
an entrepreneur and you have to
constantly
keep stuff moving and figure new things
out and solve really hard frontiers
problems all
wrapped together i always say the same
thing yeah it's funny yeah
it's it'd be great to to kind of take a
master class from uh from
maybe from you and we can we can riff on
these things but i always say
you know that and also sarah with public
speaking
those two things combined together in
outreach i feel like it's sort of a
moral obligation in the sense that you
know i'm a i'm a professor at a state
university
i'm being paid by the taxpayers if we've
gotten nsf or nasa grants we're paid by
the taxpayer
and yet we never like really exchange
the information with the public the
public is left with this
impression that well sarah and brian are
kind of like specialists and
and they work on specialized things and
i wouldn't go down to the hospital and
just start using the mri machine so
why do i think but it's a little bit
different you know because we we are
public servants in a certain sense and
then i hear from my colleagues
i'm not good at that and i say oh yeah
well were you good at quantum field
theory when you were you know 13 years
old i bet you weren't you know
even these are most brilliant people in
the world uh and uh
and no of course not so how'd you get
good at it i studied it
well you made it a priority you
dedicated resources you put in the
effort and the sweat equity and you
became good at it right
what makes you think you can't do that
as a manager as a public speaker
as an outreacher um and it's just they
just don't prioritize it so i i no
longer have sympathy for my colleagues
anymore because it's like anything else
if you want to be better at it like you
said
you know you took this class i i think
that's so cool
actually my students that are foreign
students i had students from china from
thailand from uganda
over the past decade that's one of the
best things about being a professor
right we get to meet people
we would never meet and our kids get to
meet somebody you know completely
different
religion looks different acts different
whatever and they come into our house or
we go to their house
it's one of the best parts about being
an academic but
one of the things i did is i paid for my
students to go to like a toastmasters
uh my graduation yes yes i'm so glad you
did that
and and it was great and i'm like why am
i only doing it for my students from
from you know from other countries like
my my
mate you know american-born students
they need to know it um and so i've
tried to do that it is
it does you know it listen is a little
bit more challenging but as you say
they're online resources or videos
you just have to make it a priority so
take it from these two doctors
uh brian and sarah uh that this is
something that the technically-minded
people should do
because i always say there's no skill
there's no
job description sarah and you can agree
or not but like the scientist
like it's a series of like a trillion
you know micro skills that we synthesize
together if we're successful into a
macro skill
it's true i like how you've parsed that
i want to ask you about this
the hiring situation academia we're used
to being graded and judged and and
we have this i call it the academic
hunger games
where we're like first you have to get
into a good college you know and get a
letter in high school
get into good college in college to
graduate school graduate school postdoc
post doctor faculty and but in between
postdoc and faculty a tremendous phase
transition occurs
where it's almost trivial to get a
postdoc nowadays if you're halfway
competent i mean
i've i and all my students are 100
competent but they've never been
unemployed ever after
graduating from graduate school and that
doesn't mean academia
but then it becomes impossible then it's
like i'm
into the impossible but you went into
the impossible by getting tenured
on your you know on the start opening
day of being but what do you
make of this situation and i use a
terrible analogy i'm sure you can find a
better one
it's kind of like imagine the baseball
league in america where
aaa which is the step below being in the
major leagues imagine that was easy to
get into like anybody
i could get into it um and but then
getting into the majors is just as hard
as it is now
uh what what do you attribute that to
that you know kind of there's
there's this abundance of post-doc
opportunities is it
moral to do to post-docs to set them up
for
almost certain failure it's almost
impossible to be a professor nowadays i
i would say
i think we've really ruined the system
we've done a real disservice by yeah as
you said
making a bloated postdoc level and i
think
and brian you may know the answer to
this but there is some point along the
way where funding agencies
private and government for some reason
they just wanted to have more and more
postdoc programs it's easier to get
money
to create a postdoc program than a new
faculty slot
and so that's how it happened we ended
up having way too many postdocs where
people are
essentially dedicating the prime of
their lives
and not necessarily getting to where
they want to go
and then it's it continues you know the
hunger games continue for
seven years or so until tenure can uh
take place and a lot of faculty don't
get their first independent research
grant until they're
in their 40s um and i'll maybe we need
your grad students too
because it's starting there i think
on the other hand i heard from the
president not personally but from the
president of mit it said something like
we could admit a hundred percent more
students and not dilute the quality of
mit
one bit meaning that they they reject so
many people
and there's so many qualified people out
there undergraduate yeah
and and it made me think well like
why aren't we training like imagine a
society where there was
you know twice as many mit educated
student or whatever or a ucsd education
we reject a lot of people too
um what would the world look like do we
need more scientists if we're gonna get
to the stars and you know live on mars
or the clouds surfing on venus or
whatever
he'll tell us about uh or go to trappist
like my friend adam burgasser
a former mit colleague of yours probably
uh says you know go to trappist and have
a vacation there
if we're gonna do that it seems like we
do need more stem
you know scientists and that pipeline so
on one hand we need a
a young you know cadre of people willing
to put in the work and do the training
uh we need people to train them i
suppose until ai takes over
uh like your colleague max mark and i
chatted about
uh but then finally so yeah i mean i'm
not asking for a solution but
but i mean do we need more stem people i
mean we're always hearing that we need
more stem we need more people
not so they'll go in exoplanets or any
other kind of astronomy but it's we live
in an increasing technological society i
mean think about even your car
now they all have computers and you know
when something get goes wrong
you actually have to either you have a
device or you take it to the garage and
they plug something into it
and it tells them what went wrong where
so just to have people
keep things going invent new things yes
we need a lot more people in stem
yeah and i think you had a lot of
hands-on experience with the telescopes
etcetera i want to talk a little bit
about graduate students
and and post-docs etc and being a mentor
because again it's one of these things
like being a parent
there's no manual there's no how-to
guide there's no what to expect you know
you probably
uh ruin your first one like you know my
older brother was ruined i'm convinced
uh but i'm just kidding kevin if he's
out there uh but
but i you know we don't get trained how
to do it and
i wonder you know how do you approach
the the job of mentorship it's like
it's like a biathlon being a perfect
like you have to be really good
technically
you know and like and then some you have
to like ski like hell sometimes and then
sometimes you have to like
hold your breath and focus and hold the
gun or that bow and arrow
um what is your philosophy as a as a
mentor you've had so many great you know
proteges i don't even know mentees
mentos
i don't know what you call them but but
the point is you've done a lot of what
is your philosophy in terms of
mentorship not teaching
but in terms of mentorship where i think
it's more important to have wisdom than
knowledge
in some sense yes well i always try to
get to know the student and find the
right project for the right person
because everyone has a different skill
set and a different
kind of thing that they're going to
resonate with
so that's the number one and number two
is that this and this is true i only
know the students at mit the graduate
students
but they're typically very good
technically and they may not need to be
taught
programming or but they need to be
taught a whole other set of skills like
how to think creatively
they need room to grow in that area how
to think
like a scientist how to think big and
not just like when you're an undergrad
and you're going from problem set to
problem set like predefined
set of tasks and
yeah those are and how to
how to choose a problem how to identify
something that they're going to love
doing that is actually going to
be able to make change and then there's
another set of skills we just touched on
that they often don't have like
communicating writing those ones usually
are pretty poor and so i
i try to work hard to help the
individual with what they need it's
usually not programming sometimes it is
usually these other surrounding things
that they'll need to succeed and that's
kind of the overview
you say a beautiful line in the book you
say mentors show you where to look
not only where to look but how to see
and i think you you had the benefit of
some great mentors and now
your uh your proteges are are very
fortunate to have you
as their mentor uh and it sort of like
never ends it's almost like family
i mean sometimes we spend more time with
our students and postdocs and professor
colleagues than we do with our
with our families um i'm trying to you
know coronavirus has been a time for me
to
a little bit re-evaluate that and and
kind of you know
they're they're young for only so long
and you know we were blessed to have
have children
uh and and you know wanting to feel like
well how do you
stop time and i don't ask you that maybe
you could switch another gear again go
back
and go back to the uh to the sections
that made me
tear up but but it seemed like a lot of
time in the book you wanted to time to
kind of speed up because of that old
saw time heals all wounds but on the
other hand
like we also want to pause time when
kids are only
young once and i heard you know sam
harris he's a famous you know kind of
philosopher et cetera podcaster
and he said you know the most precious
commodity there is is not even time
because we all waste time watching cat
videos or into the impossible podcast
with brian
now i wish he said that but he didn't
say that uh we all waste enough time but
it's attention he
and he claims attention is the most
precious commodity i say no
i say innocence is the most precious
commodity because like once you
i've interviewed people that are like
war veterans and stuff sarah and
they've killed people and and and
they're like i can never unsee it i can
never undo it and they needed to do it
they would have died
and it gives me chills you know to think
about that but
um but you know in the sense like if
they didn't do it they wouldn't be
talking to me
but on the other hand they can never get
it back and and so i feel how do i apply
those lessons
like wisdom is benefiting from the
failures and experiences of others so
you don't have to make them yourself
and for me i wonder like would you stop
time
or are you comfortable or would you
speed up time i mean they're the two
different things like waiting is the
hardest part
and then like i wish i could turn back
the clock which which do you cleave more
towards
well i love the concept of stopping time
for
special or poignant moments i remember
when my
second born was six months old and i
realized i wasn't gonna be having more
children
i had two which i loved dearly i really
wanted five i know you have
i think five but it just wasn't gonna
happen emotionally financially like
having the nanny
sending them to the montessori school
just the time and my energy level wasn't
happening
and i remember wow i remember six months
to 12 months being like an amazing time
with the firstborn so i'm like i gotta
hold pause time if i could
pause time i would but instead of
pausing time because of course we have
no control over that
i just took extra time to enjoy to pay
attention
spend more time in that i don't know if
you remember that phase it's so great
they're so funny like they just have
smiles and they're happy and they're
not necessarily mobile yet so they won't
just kind of go off and do stuff you can
take them anywhere
so happy and joyful so i pause time in
my own way so i think i'd go for that
pausing time
yeah i i think so too you know i always
say there's there's multiple scales of
time
where time becomes important and you
know the
the two or three hours of clock elapsed
proper time you know between dinner and
bedtime
can feel like an eternity you know
because i need water i need a graham
cracker i need to go to the bathroom i
need to go to the bathroom again
yeah they're trying to pause time
they're trying to stay on their ex
they're better than we are
and of course they want to grow up
really fast and um you know i've
actually
explored maybe not mysticism but you
know at least in judaism
there is you know there's prayer and i
started thinking like prayer i feel kind
of corny like i'm asking god
if god exists which i don't even know if
i believe 100 in either
but i'm asking god to suspend the laws
of the universe just for brian keating's
benefit
you know like when i'm when you see a
house on you know that's on
smoking or a car that's on fire praying
oh it's not mine that means you're
praying it's happening to somebody else
um so i don't know how i feel about
prayer but i see a meditative value
and i think about well like meditation
might be and i had deepak chopra on the
podcast
a couple weeks ago wow and he talked a
little bit uh about
like his like you know splitting life
into four quadrants basically like
birth and growth accumulation of
resources
expending resources and then he calls it
preparing for death
and i was like would you pause any of
those he's like i pause each one of
those by meditation in other words just
like
thinking and and contemplating i wonder
do you have any like
daily habits or rich now that your kids
are a little bit older and it's not like
hmm well they need to go to the hospital
today you know like and they're really
really
well the one broke his apparently he
broke his hand the other day no no he's
sorry yeah it's okay he's old enough to
figure it out on
his own so he came back from a soccer
game and his
hand was really hurting a lot and he's
like well i'm not gonna go to the doctor
because they're not gonna do anything
and then a week later he's like huh my
hand still hurts just as much i think i
should probably
go to the doctor so do you have any like
daily rituals or weekly rituals do you
have any
you know signpost to mark times passage
other than the seasons obviously
on a daily basis or a seasonal basis or
the quarter system or semester
i mean i wish i had a really great
philosophical deep answer for you
but i don't really i mean i try to take
some time each day to reflect
just on that day or the week and i i do
think about my
goals like personal and professional and
ask can i do better
what's not getting my attention you know
what's my main thing i want to
move forward so i have that kind of
level but
and i'm also jewish as you may or may
not know i know
not very observant but we do try to
catch the
important holidays like passover i'm not
sure if you want a time stamp on this
but passover
passover's coming up soon and we usually
have a brisket
or something in a special meal and we
used to go through the whole
seder but lately i think
we're just going to tell the passover
story you know not go through every
element
and just so for fun we're gonna have
turkey this year because we accidentally
got two turkeys at thanksgiving and one
of them has been up so much space in the
freezer we have to have a certification
not the same freezer that took of a cat
is it sarah no no okay thank god thank
god
you still have that same freezer but
that's not where the turkey is right now
so uh so not um
not as contemplative as you um yeah i
mean
it's it's sort of a develop i mean
nothing can like i said nothing can
prepare you
for a kid nothing can prepare you for
the loss of a parent you know
uh and and the other other challenges
but but i think you know history
as a sum total i think we'd be fools to
ignore
even if you don't believe like i had
freeman dyson on many times on the
podcast
and he would say look god's existence
can't be really
proven wrong it can't be proven right so
it's a mystery
and the mystery is different than a
puzzle he said i love solving puzzles
because
there's a solution i might not be able
to solve it brian keating but
freeman could solve it or sarah can
solve it but a mystery is something like
very delicious because nobody can solve
it and and maybe nobody can solve it and
maybe that's the point
and you know i just love kind of
thinking about these these
traditions um as a you know conservative
small c
in that you know you're you're thinking
about these things that have been handed
out for thousands of years
in in most cases or it could be
something new i mean i've spoken for
atheist churches called the
sunday assembly the ethical humanist
society of chicago
is one of the oldest ones that spoke
there i love it because they get
together they give charity
they sing hymns you know they do reading
of course it's you know it's from like
uh philip roth or or carl sagan or
something
that's fine i don't care i don't care
because
my belief is that people have religions
you know whether they know it or not
whether they admit it or not i mean mit
is a religion
there's so much lore associated with
where you are and people just like do
anything to get in there and
and it becomes like this this idle you
know and it could be a good thing
uh that's for sure but you know some
people's pinnacle of of
of their lives is going there or getting
in there and and
for good reason it is a wonderful
institution but i think it's important
to have rituals you know kind of outside
of of your work and and have at least
one day i command my graduate students
i'm not god but i say
you can't work six days seven days a
week otherwise you are
like enslaved you may love your work you
may be a total nerd
and love it so much but you need time to
relax you need time to breathe and that
comes through in the book because
you take time out and one of the
greatest triumphs of your life had
nothing to do with the lab
nothing at all and it's out in nature
it's closer to me than you in the grand
canyon
i'll save that for the reader but the
importance of nature comes through and
was that always something you know is
that just built into you as a canadian
uh by birth it's built in but it goes
back to your previous point
about any meditation or deep
contemplative thought and
that's what nature does for me that's
like my meditation
and a lot of people i think so i always
love going out and spending the day
outside
doing hiking or in the past canoeing or
what have you but yes
definitely yeah it does seem to reach
that state of what uh
people call flow i'm having stephen
cutler who's written a lot of books with
peter diamandis who is a mit
alum uh you may know peter diamandis
writes a lot of books about exponential
growth and so forth but he has a book
called
um the art of the impossible i think
and he's coming on to talk about flow
states and how you get into them
and how they're very much drug-like but
it's kind of like a healthy drug because
you make it yourself right yeah
and of course you can go too much and do
you know too much adrenaline uh
junkying but um okay so next i want to
go to this very important topic how we
met the first time
with your wonderful handsome husband
brilliant husband charles daryl put me
in touch with you i thank charles so
much for doing that
and that was on the occasion of an
announcement made back in september i
believe it was
of a discovery of a molecule on venus
known as phosphine which my crude
attempt to think about is kind of like
uh ammonia but with a knight with a
phosphorus molecule is that right there
you can think of it that way so talk
about uh what that discovery
was all about and what is the status of
that discovery
now well in looking for signs of life
elsewhere
we're trying to find gases that don't
belong
and believe it or not it was nearly 100
years ago james jeans and
famous astronomer thought about this he
acknowledged that in our atmosphere here
on earth oxygen
fills our atmosphere to 20 by volume but
without
photosynthetic life plants and
photosynthetic bacteria
there'd be virtually no oxygen right and
so even we wrote about wow you could
look for a gas somewhere else and that
doesn't belong like oxygen here on earth
it's highly reactive
it wouldn't be in our atmosphere unless
it's continually replenished
well my team studies a lot of different
gases that we might look for on other
planets far away and one of the gases we
became enamored with is phosphine
because on earth it's only associated
with life
no other way and and little did we know
that
a radio astronomer in the uk professor
jane greaves
was also thinking about phosphine and
she purposely
went out on purposefully went out on a
limb and decided to search for signs of
life on venus
and she dug through the literature and
came across some of the same papers we
found
in biology explaining that phosphine is
it's very very strongly associated with
life on earth and she
pointed the radio telescope james clerk
maxwell telescope she pointed alma
at venus and a mutual contact connected
us because we were our teams were each
working on phosphine
and we joined professor jane greaves
team to
work on phosphine last september the
team made a big announcement about
finding a signal of phosphine on venus
and we explained that no matter
what kind of chemistry process you think
about whether it's lightning or
volcanoes or meteorite
delivery or surface minerals being
upswept from the surface
there's no way that we know how to make
oxygen on venus
in the amounts required and these
amounts are tiny just like parts per
billion
so we speculated perhaps i mean we have
no way to know of course but
maybe it's life-producing philosophy so
that was a big announcement the world
loved it
the chemists hated it by the way they uh
on social media and email chains they've
been negatively wild in a very angry way
and now we're about six months later i
just wanted you to know there's no
that that i know of there's no published
paper coming up with a chemical process
that can produce phosphine on venus yeah
despite all that
what's not as rosy of a picture is
astronomers looked at the data
and for one of the data sets alma so far
no other group who's looked at this data
has found a signal of phosphine
we stand by our our data analysis
with the james clerk maxwell telescope
data people have revisited that as well
and what's the great thing about
astronomy today is we always make our
data public
pretty much always and when people look
at the
jcmt data they do find a signal and
those groups who find that signal
they work hard to say it's not phosphine
that instead it is another gas there's a
gas sulfur dioxide and right at the
moment where we're at
is that we're finding that sulfur
dioxide might explain a tiny amount of
the signal but
so far we can't see a way that it
explains the whole signal because you'd
need
far more sulfur dioxide you know than
has ever been seen on venus
so we're still waiting for this to
unfold actually
and this is something that might take a
long time
think about methane on mars if you've
interviewed anyone on that one it's 15
years later
i think most people believe there's
methane on mars but it's still somewhat
controversial
yeah i mean of course there have been a
lot of a lot of great discoveries that
kind of
attract a lot of attention including
discoveries i've participated in
and you know one thing i i and i'm not
this is not a criticism of the current
uh description that you made but
but maybe preceding uh events including
maybe my own even
is that you know the public will find
out and it will always be on page one
you know the new york times the boston
globe or whatever you guys have over
there
the san diego union tribune over here
for my friends over there
but uh but then if there is a question
or there is even
you know god forbid a retraction a
recantation
uh then it's on you know page b you know
52 of the saturday edition that's the
least red of all seven edition
uh so i feel like you know my
controversial you know proposals that
experiments should keep in reserve a
budget equal to
you know 25 percent of their pr uh for
retractions and and i also think it
goes along with what we said competently
with the fact we never get taught
uh how to teach how to be mentors how to
be parents whatever
but we also never get taught like what
are the ethics of being a professor you
know
making this announcement like if a
professor needs to get tenure
and then or or here our graduate student
needs to graduate
you know and and they might have
questions and maybe they don't go ahead
with their with their concerns because
they're
so there's no ethical training i mean
there is formally yes you don't
copy research you quote services you
don't plagiarize but
very different from the kind of unique
events that go on
so um anyway that's just kind of right i
know but back to this phosphine for a
moment
i mean i think the good thing about
modern day practices is we make our
scripts public the data's public
and people have a chance to to to work
through it all actually
and i think actually in the case of
phosphine i don't know if it's been
front page news but it's been pretty
front and center the controversy is
is quite well out there being discussed
so yeah right
there's this really interesting thing
about phosphine so let's phosphine aside
this um debate this controversy
this discussion it has shawn like
re-shined a light on venus
and it's helped people see i mean you
have a lot of kids isn't it true there's
always
the ignored sibling usually the one
sibling who gets all the attention and
at the opposite end there's one who's
always ignored
yeah i always say venus is that ignorant
right mars gets all the
yeah mars is getting all the attention
so this amazing thing is happening now
we're um working really hard on a
mission concept
small medium and large three different
ones or repeated small ones to go to
venus
and to search for not just phosphine but
other gases that are out of equilibrium
that don't belong we're going to search
for signs of life and maybe even life
itself
independent of my work uh there's other
people there's a young
person on the team a postdoc who
actually
um he wrote a photochemistry code to
help explain
the presence of fossen and he decided to
apply it to venus in general not now not
talking about phosphine and he's
actually
seems like he's been able to explain a
couple of long-standing chemical
anomalies in the venus atmosphere
and this sort of in a roundabout lay
could like imagine if there's
imagine a universe where okay the
phosphine debate kind of goes on but it
enabled
us to find signs of life or life itself
through a totally different pathway but
just because the phosphine debate
brought being a venus back to the
forefront
yeah that was kind of the ultimate in
extremophiles that you were talking
about
earlier and you mentioned in the book
that there were you know you have this
theory and what i love is the candor in
the book like you have this theory with
some postdocs that like
maybe every gas is produced by life in
an atmosphere
and then like you went to someone at
harvard uh uh
name escapes me right now but he said no
there's plenty here's like three of them
and you say as an aside
only he named multiple are there
multiple ones that aren't produced by
life
and as an aside only one would have been
sufficient you know it kind of reminded
me of
of uh there was a book in 1929 written
uh it was titled a hundred scientists
against albert einstein and it was all
these german
nazis scientists that were dismayed that
he had left germany and gone to america
and was
besmirching and several of them were
nobel laureates but einstein is reported
to have quipped
uh if i was really wrong it would have
only required one person
just thinking about that when dear um i
want to talk a little bit uh
and so i'll have links to the venus life
website is that still one of the premier
places for people
to go yeah okay good you can get updates
there about we put news articles there
so yes
and i'm still hoping to get jane on the
podcast at some point
um and i i do follow it and and i i do
wait one more thing about that that i
forgot to do so for a professor doing
greaves right now
it's a full-time job just responding to
all of these
um all the articles coming out saying
phosphine either the signal's not there
or the signal is there but it's not
phosphate it's it's literally
a full-time job for her i believe it and
i want to explore that dark side if you
will
indulge me with some forbearance uh
sarah so
um you may know your crosstown neighbor
uh
avi loeb uh came out with a
controversial book uh
which at the end of which mentions your
discoveries of
potential discovery of phosphine
produced potentially by life on
venus and uh that's that towards the end
of the book and
and but in the mid in the meantime he's
gotten a tremendous amount not not for
that
but a tremendous amount of criticism uh
for this discovery
that he claims omua this was this
interstellar
uh interloper that wasn't uh was not
naturally made that it was made not by
man
or woman but by some sentient technology
some civilization
uh the direction of which is completely
unknown to him but nevertheless that the
preponderance of evidence of course he's
a good scientist a great scientist
i would never say it's 100 sure that it
is um
i wanted to get your reaction to a
couple things one is
the back reaction that he got from
people in his own department which i had
seen
emails and confidential things from uh
and and also from the whole astronomical
community
accusing him of various things from you
know sexism
to uh to uh you know basically
uh self-aggrandizement arrogance and i
said look
you know the guy's israeli and the
nickname for israelis is the cactus so
you gotta gotta expect he's gonna be a
little bit prickly and he's gonna fight
back
uh but i felt and i sense even to this
day some of the
attention is caused by avi i think he he
displayed a poor
uh lack of respect and collegiality for
jill tarter in a well-known video
he's apologized to her as i understand
it um but
uh but so there's some self-inflicted
wounds but i sensed another
sort of um amount of heat that came down
and that was not scientific even though
it was perpetrated by other scientists
uh can you say something about that when
it's not like you've discovered a new
type of
you know type 2 superconductor you know
it's not going to cause you know
a the same headlines but b the same
hostility and i wonder you know if it's
if it's true um that some of the
negative attention
is is coming because the stakes are so
high jealousy
envy or um what your reaction is and how
you handle it
are you talking about phosphine now yeah
phosphine and yeah first phosphine and
then
if you want to comment on what's going
on with avi though um
maybe you have more insight into this i
have no idea why people were so hostile
the chemists especially unbelievably
hostile and like i said they didn't
follow up we welcome
please write a paper you know you can
exclude us from
you know how you get to suggest who not
to review exclude us um
we just haven't seen that and even the
the observers
you know some of them would send us a
note saying you know you can
or they in the abstract said okay you
can retract now we're not going to
retract now
like it's we're not like why would we we
still find a signal in the way we
analyze the data
but that level of anger was just i've
never seen that before
and i i don't know i don't know what it
is actually
and you know phosphine or not uh i don't
know if this will sound arrogant but
we like i or we were influencers you
know that word they use influencers yeah
like
dog items or fashion right now this is
popular now
yeah that's that's just the fact
actually yeah
so don't know so what do you think it is
i think there's a combination i think i
i did send sort of a patronizing
you know kind of uh malice in some sense
that
that you know yes the chemist or the
astrochemist or the astrobiologist
you know you're you're out of your depth
you're out of your lane whatever you
want to say
and i you know i don't know jane at all
you know personally professor jane
greaves
uh but i'm hoping to as they say to have
her on the podcast talk about her work
as well
but i feel like there is a certain
amount of it's almost impossible not to
get attention you know all the
press conferences those were very rare
until the 1980s there was never like a
press conference
yeah and i i think it's dangerous you
know turns it into this celebrity
and and fashion and so forth when you
know that's not really what science is
about and i had this conversation
the thing is you've got to drill down
then then you've got to work with nature
and
science and the other prominent journals
and say look please don't do this just
let people talk about it all along let
them get
feedback you know don't don't hold it
there but i just want to give you one
example of hostility the reason why i
like i didn't take any of this
personally and i didn't think that
oh we don't know what we're doing like i
never thought that because one of the
very first things that happened was a
prominent
planetary scientist who led one of the
big missions
immediately like email blasted this list
that has like a few hundred people and
said
ugh we all know well i don't know what
the tone was but it actually just said
look
we all know that jupiter and saturn have
phosphine
as if to dismiss phosphine as even ever
been able to be associated by life but
jupiter and saturn have a lot of
hydrogen venus has almost no hydrogen
jupiter and saturn have high
temperatures and pressures beneath their
atmosphere
phosphine phosphorus wants to be with
hydrogen in that case
and so on venus it's really totally
opposite so we saw some stuff that just
made no sense right off the bat and
that's how
that's how i knew people were being
hostile not that they were being
righteous they were factually correct
even so that's that's part of it
yeah i mean i had a little taste of that
with bicep too and and people coming out
of the woodwork
and the announcement and saying uh oh
it you know it's definitely it's
definitely from this foreground
synchron radiation and it can explain
everything by magnetic fields
and uh in our galaxy alone and so
and then in the end they're saying see i
was right because i said it was
foregrounds all along and so
but it wasn't from synchrotron or
somebody said it was from
you know anomalous systematic effect
that we had that we had actually
published a paper on
to rule that out as a source but because
we
were clear that we didn't understand the
underlying cause of it but we limited it
excluded it from being a cause of
the b mode signal potentially from
inflation that we were claiming
punitively uh to have detected uh oh we
were right it was a systematic
and so yeah there there is unavoidably
there's this phenomenon that you know
italians have some term for it and it
means like
you get shot the most when you're over
the target
and uh and and i think it's a sign
you're right you know these these things
it's impossible for them not to affect
you at all but on the same token
the fact that you're getting attention
for it means that other scientists are
taking you seriously
i think that's where avi is a little bit
um you know kind of uh
distracted by a lot of the criticism i
mean he will point out
you know so and so you know just you
know that's criticizing me hasn't
written a single paper and here's
76 papers that i've written just about a
muammua
but i also think that there's you know
there's a risk when you talk about alien
life i mean it's just it's impossible
not to conjure up
you know uh you know science fiction
movies and and
you know bad forehead prosthetic
foreheads and and
on camera and i think you know that
doesn't mean it's not it's not worth
doing but i think
it lends itself and that we've had you
know we have professor shelly wright
here who's a good friend of mine a
colleague at ucsd
and you know she struggles she's one of
the few people who you know can confer
degrees
in the search for extraterrestrial
technology i mean charlotte's certainly
there's only a couple of handful of
groups and avi claims you know there's
only
you know there's fewer than one hand one
alien hand which only has four fingers
as we know
but uh but i do think there's kind of
that a little bit of envy
uh that can take place in in the
profession i think it can be amplified
by by
you know secrecy so it's good to be open
as open as possible i think that was one
thing we could have done
a little bit better uh back then but i
want to ask you you know in the closing
moments that we have if you have a
little bit more time i want to
uh talk uh about uh well there is one
you know it's funny because you do say
in the book like as an offhand copy say
venus is too hot for life i mean you do
say that in one part of the book
so that's the only typo i could find in
the entire book because we don't know if
venus is too hot for life right
um i'm hoping i'm hoping that you're
right i want to ask about collaboration
so i did a study when i was writing my
book the of of a bunch of
studies on nobel prize winning
collaborations so these are most
successful collaborations
and they tended to dis to uh to dissolve
soon after the nobel prize was awarded
soon after the discovery was confirmed
and there was just a lot of like
jealousy and rivalry um
is there a danger in some of the work
that you're doing like you might be a
victim of your own success like you've
accomplished so much
um so so quickly and and you're paving
the way forward
uh but do you ever worry about the
health of a collaboration and how best
to maintain it
under these stressful circumstances
because you never get trained and like
here's how to
speak to the media a we never get
trained here's how to react when people
are speaking in the media about you
so how do you nucleate cultivate and you
know kind of inculcate these values
in your collaboration uh fellow team
members
that's a tough one i don't that's really
a hard question
right now i was my mind actually went to
a slightly different topic right now and
that is that
you know when any kind of young
astronomer working in exoplanets
exoplanet atmospheres
thinks they're going to find signs of
life on an exoplanet atmosphere
and they might yeah and it's the problem
of the field growing too big for the
resources we have at hand
i mean the real heroes when you want to
think about it are the ones who built
the james webb space telescope
but now there's any number of an end
user so it's different from your work
where you had to get the money get the
strategy build everything from scratch
deploy it get the data here we are using
like the
we hope to use the james webb space
telescope i'm a giant facility
but it's almost like a lottery who's
going to be the one to get to observe
the planet
that if it does end up having having a
sign of life so we have
a lot of competition not in a
collaboration but
kind of in the whole community i think
there's a lot of
i mean there's collaboration but there's
also a lot of angst i think
yeah it's another one of these you know
kind of tortured analogies that i it's
like
in in minor league baseball you can
imagine the pitcher
who's like trying to get in the major
leagues you know himself you know but
like
also trying to help younger people get
into the major leagues by giving them
good balls to hit out of the park you
know it's like
we train our competition right and my
postdoc is going to go and compete
for the same resources and the the late
great andrew lang my
my very close friend father figure to me
mentor
he used to you know kind of jokingly say
like i'm in the only profession where
i'm trying to like
like reduce my chances of success at
winning nsf grants by
producing good postdocs but that's you
know it's just another kind of weird
aspect of being a professor but would
you have it any other way would you do
any other job what would you be doing if
you weren't
mit famous professor genius grant
recipient
sarasota what are you in the multiverse
if it's true
i mean if i wasn't in science i really i
don't know i feel like i could have done
a great job in industry being you know
founding and being ceo of a giant
company that hopefully did something
beneficial and impactful for society
i think about that but it's more like
maybe i'd be a rabbi who's not really
sure if he believes in god but
we'll take that up some other time uh
what are the most exciting
um uh things that you're working on now
uh with your team you you talk a lot
about the star shade what's this what's
the status of that
um and uh obviously you already talked
about jwst but other other missions and
uh especially the coronagraphs i don't
know if we can even say that since covet
but
uh how what how how are coronagraphs
faring in this
in this age well coronagraph and star
shade alike were
for our big mission in space that would
be like the next james webb space
telescope we're actually waiting on the
astronomy and asked the u.s astronomy
and astrophysics to catal survey
yeah to come out with their every decade
you know they meet and make a
rank ordered priority list and so we're
all waiting to see if we got in the
number one slot slot there
so that kind of is is a bit on hold
people are reluctant to spend a lot of
money or
make a lot of effort until that report
comes out which i think should be soon
right
yeah yeah it's funny because you you
mentioned in the book you talk a lot
about lyman spitzer who was
uh who was at princeton for many years
where you were a postdoc
and um his son is one of my colleagues
here at nick spitzer
yeah he's a uh he's a neuroscientist
here at ucsd
a member of the national academy one of
the most likely sorry
i knew that because ironically my former
neighbor across the street her name's
lydia spencer
oh really and nikki i believe is her
uncle i want to say nick is her uncle
could they yeah
and i think i met him once yeah um got a
big handlebar
yeah that's right yeah lydia her maiden
name was spitzer lydia spencer my
former neighbor yeah you would love nick
i'm not sure that would be the name but
yeah that's right i remember that
you would love nick i hope you guys give
me because he's an ice climber he he
goes and climbs mountains with a nice
pick
and climbs and you're just so much more
adventurous than i am
okay sarah well we're reaching the end
when i ask questions
of a more kind of a metaphysical rather
than physics level i hope you're willing
to do that that's called going into the
impossible
sarah are you willing to go into the
impossible and answer my final three
thrilling questions i'm willing to go
there i'm not quite sure
if my answers will satisfy okay well
they won't beat they won't be too
they hopefully won't be too onerous for
you okay the first question
uh is uh is is relates around what is
known as an
ethical will not a material will but an
ethical will
and i was kind of inspired to to look
into this both by
its prominence and judaism it features
very largely in judaism it's known as
uh and it's sort of the end of the
old testament the the book of
deuteronomy
is not about deuterons but about uh the
second naming
and so forth it's really moses's ethical
will what does he want the
children of israel which he won't get
into his promised land
but they will and what does he want them
to know in terms of wisdom not in terms
of money
so what i want to ask you what would you
leave
to members of your ideological errors
which you know i might count myself as
one of them not necessarily your
biological heirs
what piece of wisdom when you hit the
age that moses was 120 years old
and you depart this mortal coil what
wisdom
or learning would you like to impart to
people that come after you
in terms of ethics or or anything i'd
like to give
well the one that ethics popped into my
head was you know how sometimes
you're faced with an a dilemma and you
don't really know what the right
right choice but actually you do know
because deep inside you know if you feel
like it's wrong it's
wrong and so that wisdom is to listen to
your inner voice
wow and just kind of just don't
overanalyze don't overthink just ask
yourself
what is is this right is this wrong and
you'll you'll know the right answer
that's really lovely uh thank you very
much we're also gonna now the second
question
takes us deeper into the future than
ever before
i don't know if you ever saw uh the
movie 2001 a space odyssey
so by the way that's what charles is i
want to say that's probably charles's
favorite movie
really wonderful we resonate very much
together mine is moana but still um but
uh
so in that movie there are features very
prominently
a structure known as a monolith it's
sort of this object that is
kind of menacing we don't know what it's
for there are hominids in africa two
million years ago and they hit it with a
bone nothing happens to it
later on it goes into outer space and
it's on the surface of the moon or
there's another one there
seems to be put by an ancient alien
civilization
maybe coming from mars but but any are
from venus rather
and uh and that civilization has put
this monolith there as sort of a time
capsule
and uh and i want to ask you if you had
a time capsule
that could last as this thing did for
hundreds of millions of years
what information what what knowledge
would you put on it
in it around it you know don't make it a
usb because i don't think they'll have
readers and i'm billionaires but but
what would you inscribe
on it as a summary of maybe the the
knowledge that you've gleaned or the
wisdom of humanity as a whole
well that's that's a big question
how much space do you imagine on this
well you can write in zero point
font and i'll i'll give you a little
guide how richard feynman answered the
question
if you like but uh but but he you know
he's only virtually on my show so
i guess i'd want to capture both like
our biggest disasters as humanity and
also our biggest achievements
and you have to go away and think about
what those those actually are
like you think of the world wars you
think of overpopulation as being the bad
things
and some of the great ones we've solved
like the ozone hole you know we actually
figured out that chemistry not not me
but you know mario molino and others who
was here at ucsd yeah he was all right
and he well and he was at mit of course
yes
that's true he was at ucsd you know just
sorry sorry that's just you know solving
that problem
and changing coolants so that we could
not have that problem so i kind of want
to capture like the biggest
horrendous disasters we had and then
also the ones that
that we we overcame and the good things
that we did as humanity
wow you know lessons learned time
capsule yeah
that's right not just we were here but
we mattered yeah i asked andrew
and it was carl sagan's widow i asked
her you know what would you put on it
or in it and uh she's like i already did
that
what are you talking about she was her
brain waves were recorded on the voyager
1 golden disc
uh right after she fell in love with
carl sagan so it's very poignant to uh
to hear that from her okay sarah last
question before you go back
to ordering canada so what does it mean
that you're a member you're the order of
canada
you're an officer what do i have to
salute you what does that mean
um well officer of the order of canada
is
it's like an honorary position like one
of the
medals of achievement the united states
will give to its citizens ah
wonderful okay uh last question
now we're gonna go backwards in time
sarah we went forwards in time a billion
years just a second ago
now we're going to go backwards in time
but by the way to hear all of sarah's
answers you're going to have to
subscribe to the newsletter that i put
out and
many of our guests are co-subscribers
and that you can get at ryankeating.com
you'll get sarah's answers to the
thrilling three and maybe a giveaway or
two
well we're talking about some fun
giveaways before we start a recording
but to hear sarah's answers you're gonna
have to go subscribe uh
to the mailing list but the final
question for professor sarah seeger
an inspiration to many uh including me
is going backwards in time sarah so uh
sir arthur c
clarke again so i'm the co-director here
at ucsd of the arthur c clark center for
human imagination
and as part of that we run the into the
impossible podcast
the name of which derives from one of
arthur's famous three laws
one of which is any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and the
voice you hear
saying that at the beginning of each one
of my recordings is sir arthur c
clarke saying that famous phrase his
second law which i use around the
faculty meetings
is for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert
and his third law is the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and i want to ask you sarah i have my
suspicions but i want to ask you as a 20
year old a 30 year old
advice to your former self what advice
would you give to give
younger version of sarah the courage
to go as you did into the impossible
well i think i would tell the younger
version and to all those people out
there who are different
in some way that you can take advantage
of that
difference if you're really different in
some way from
everyone around you you can actually use
that to your advantage in the future
really lovely sarah and i want to thank
you so much not only for your time today
but for
this gift uh to astronomers to lay
people
um it's really it's really as close as
you could get
to maybe not a how-to guy not a manual
on how to
do all these things uh that that you've
accomplished in
in your in your life but to um to really
serve as a
as a guiding point that you're not alone
and that there are
fellow small lights in the universe and
i found a very poignant
extremely emotional i'm very proud of
myself i may not be a
member of an officer of some order of of
cal
of canada of some maple leaf or whatever
but i made it through without crying
i did choke up i i promised you i would
get for clamped
but i didn't lose it and i'm very proud
of myself sarah
because you are a spectacular writer an
amazing individual and i'm honored to
uh that you spent your time with me
today thank you so much brian it was a
pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
do
[Music]
you